and update on Peters Schrager stealing
one of our questions that we posed on
Monday there's an i-team report and it's
it's pretty brutal pretty pretty intense
you know as journalists we should invite
Peter Schrager on to ask him about
stealing one of our ideas on this show
is this the first time that he's stolen
because maybe he'd like to admit
something else he we're combing through
his Twitter you see this is how it
starts
all of a sudden bread crumbs and then
we're gonna find out did Peter swagger
win a sports yummy or something because
they may want to just throw it out there
day we were talking about Julian Edelman
even during the broadcast of the
Patriots game Jim Nantz and Tony Romo
were talking about Edelman as a
potential hall-of-famer
and Paulie said do you think Edelman's a
Hall of Famer and I said no I don't I
think he's very good but I don't think
he's a hall-of-famer I think he's great
in the postseason and Paulie goes okay
let's see let's do a comparison and then
we were wondering about other receivers
if you would put them in there and
Paulie goes alright Julian Edelman or
Calvin Johnson whose career would you
want would you want a couple of Super
Bowls or would you want to be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer and one of
the great regular-season wide receivers
of all time and so that was our debate
on Monday and all of a sudden about 35
minutes ago
Paulie sends me a tweet from Peter
Schreyer who's been a you know a
contributor to the show friend of the
show works for the NFL Network good
morning football and it said hey a
little fun topic here to toss around
whose career would you rather have
Julian Edelman or Calvin Johnson
I said Paulie what's Peter Stryker doing
and Paulie goes well maybe somebody gave
him that topic I said did he give you
credit he did not let's go right to the
source Peter Schrager the NFL insider
author of two books graduate of Emory
University although that's in question
right now a Peter Schrager joining us
good morning Peter hi Dan I have a new
idea for good morning football a guest
comes on we're gonna ask them they're
hiding their weight a little god
[Laughter]
this was news to me
I am mortified I'm walking around
Brooklyn right now with a bag over my
head can't believe this happened the
truth matter is I'm at my local little
coffee shop deli and the guy always
talked me up and he threw this one out
of nowhere and I thought it was fresh
off his dome I thought it was perfect I
went right to Twitter I said alright
let's settle it in the great online
marketplace of Twitter you know today's
coffee shops and immediately the Dan
Patrick show army seized on it and
jumped on me and I have been getting
beat up to the last hour and I got to
apologize I got to come clean I had no
idea but this is like Rutherford Behe's
coming out with a speech and saying four
score or seven years ago a terrible
awful on my part but it's a great
question and Pauly's right it's a
fantastic debate is there any response
from the coffee shop
I mean this guy this guy's dead to me
now my good name has been besmirched I'm
not going to name the coffee shop at the
coffee shop slice bakery I'm sure that
mclovin has been there he knows the
neighborhood well but we're not gonna
name it we're certainly not gonna give
it any free code right now
Paulie you're checking on Schrader's
transcripts from Emory University no
response from Emory at this juncture
okay okay my name is that even my name I
don't know anymore well can you believe
all right why don't you answer the
question would you rather be Julian
Edelman or Calvin Johnson
I think Calvin Johnson is going to go
down as one of the all-time greats but
it's almost the same as the Marino vs
Eli debate like whose career would you
rather have Marino has all the records
but Eli's the Super Bowl champion so I
believe only when did we do Marino in 50
second hour debate it's the same today
yeah and there be a anything anything
else you want to live from us we ask
that question who's a better analyst
Kyle Brandt or Ross Tucker who's a
better eye a league analyst we asked
that one that was a January 2017 so many
there's only so many conversations out
there I guess keep your head up though
we're gonna teach other in Atlanta I'm
gonna put a brown paper bag over my head
you know and I'm gonna keep lugging
around that raker grill with you know
well we were gonna call it a Schrager
grill but anymore but you know what it
was gonna be it was gonna be stolen meat
because apparently that's what you lead
the league in there you got more swipes
and Ricky Henderson here hey you're
great sport and I hope you get a chance
to come by this said we'd love to have
you come by this oh no we'd love to have
you come on we appreciate that and hey
keep your head up all right Peter
Schrager the co-host even though there's
four people on Good Morning football NFL
Network for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]